JENNY BROWN: Choosing
the right database
can feel like a never
ending series of questions.
Structured or unstructured data?
Scale or consistency?
Relational or nonrelational?
And wait-- what
about reliability?
Stay tuned to see how
Critter Junction narrows
the scope of their search to
get some much needed answers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it comes time to
choose the right database
for your application needs,
it's all about trade-offs.
Each database product
you'll run into
has plenty of
differentiators and features,
all designed to help
you find the best
fit for your situation--
which on one side,
is good, but can also
lead to analysis paralysis.
And this is where Critter
Junction found themselves
when we met up with them.
They were looking for a database
for a new web and mobile mini
game.
Fortunately, while looking at
the cascade of database options
in Google Cloud, we
helped them match up
each product to their
potential business needs
by focusing heavily on vertical
versus horizontal scaling.
Narrowing the
scope of the search
was helpful for Critter
Junction and let
them evaluate their options
through the lens of scale.
First, we took a look at SQL, or
more specifically, Cloud SQL--
a managed database offering
for MySQL, PostgreSQL, and SQL
Server--
a modern offering for a
tried and true classic.
Cloud SQL is a great fit for
any application with loads
of structured data
that's looking
for that sweet spot of
convenience, configuration
options, and performance.
The familiarity alone could
make this a helpful option
for Critter Junction.
But again, for this search,
we're focusing on scaling.
The best part is that Cloud
SQL gives you flexible control
over scaling and deployment.
It'll wait for
you to decide when
and how to grow with
high availability
and replication built in.
Whether you need
vertical scaling
to instances with
higher CPU and memory
or adding read replicas to
achieve horizontal scaling,
it's all up to you.
But since Critter
Junction's elite gamers
couldn't handle any
downtime during resizing
and need to be able to fetch the
latest updates from each read
replica, Cloud SQL wasn't
the perfect choice.
And once you reach a certain
database size or 4,000
concurrent connections,
it might be
time to look at another option.
So let's turn things up a notch.
When you want the ability to
go from small to massive scale,
Spanner is your answer.
As a fully managed
relational database service,
it handles nearly unlimited
horizontal scaling for you.
It's also got automatic data
sharding and replication,
giving you that 99.999%
uptime that your data admins
and users are so fond of.
And while Spanner is the
backbone of billion user
services like Gmail
and YouTube, it
might be a little too powerful
for Critter Junction's
new minigame alone.
So let's reel it back in a
bit to find a better match.
Cloud Firestore sits
a little further
towards the opposite
end of the spectrum.
It'll handle horizontal
scaling for you,
but where Spanner focuses
on global consistency,
availability, and
volume, Firestore also
focuses on developer
flexibility.
Specifically, Firestore
can sync your data directly
with client applications
through real-time listeners
and support your hierarchical
data structures with real time
querying and offline support.
Firestore scales up
automatically with no downtime.
This lets Firestore
handle thousands
of requests per second, millions
of concurrent connections,
automatic data replication,
and strong consistency.
This means Firestore could
offer the flexibility
that our Critter
Junction game devs need,
while also giving them the scale
for their application size.
Sounds like a win for Firestore.
While Firestore might be
great to handle things
like configurations, friends
lists, and game services,
it's a novice when
it comes to big data.
And for Critter
Junction's analytics team,
that's a big deal, as they
need a separate database
system for their needs.
But that's something we'll talk
about in the next episode, when
we dive deeper into
their full architecture
and explore Spanner, Big Table,
and Memorystore, as well.
Even though we've only
scratched the surface,
Critter Junction already has
a pretty solid starting point
with Firestore for
their mini game
and is ready to start
designing a larger
system to suit their needs.
Next time, we'll show you how
they grew their architecture
and database
solutions from here.
Check out the links
below to learn more.
And remember, always
be architecting.